สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensive  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ด้วยการฟังค่ะอืมนะวันนี้ก็มาพบกับครูบี
แล้วก็ครูชินะคะเรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะ
วันเนี้ยวันพฤหัสสบดีค่ะอ่าวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 14 ค่ะครูบีเดือนอะไร
คะครูชิเดือนธันวาคมค่ะอ่าเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่แล้วเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
แล้วค่ะอ่ะปีพ.ศแบบไทยล่ะคะ
อืมปีค.ศรอคะพ.ศหรือคริสต์ศักราช
2023 ค่ะครูบีวันนี้เราก็มาพบกันวัน
พฤหัสสบดีที่ 14 ธันวาคม
2566 คริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะอืนะบอกแล้วว่าเดี๋ยวเราจะได้มา
เจอกันอีกนะครูชิครั้งที่แล้วเราก็ได้เจอ
กันแต่น่าจะผ่านไปประมาณ 2 อาทิตย์แล้วนะ
คะไม่ได้เจอครูอืมวันนี้เรามาเจอกันค่ะ
แต่วันเนี้ยเรามาเจอกันเนี่ยเราก็ต้องตาม
คำขอค่ะเพราะว่าเราบอกว่าการที่นักเรียน
เนี่ยมาทำงานในประเทศไทยหรือคนไทยทำงานใน
ประเทศไทยก็ตามเนี่ยคเราก็สามารถเอ่อลา
งานได้นะมีสิทธิ์ลงานได้ตามกฎหมายไทยอืม
นะก็แปลว่าวันนี้เราจะมาคุยเรื่องการทำ
งานแต่เราไม่อยากทำงานหรอคะใช่ค่ะเวลาเรา
ไม่อยากทำงานเนี่ยเราสามารถไม่ไปทำงานได้
ด้วยแบบด้วยการลาค่ะทีนี้เราต้องมีเหตุผล
ในการลานะไม่ใช่อยู่ๆเอ่อดิฉันขอลางาน 1
วันเพราะว่าขี้เกียจทำงานอันนี้ไม่ได้นะ
คะออใช่มันต้องมีเหตุผลจะบอกจะโทรศัพท์ไป
บอกที่ทำงานไปบอกออฟฟิศว่าวันนี้ไม่ไปทำ
งานนะคะขี้เกียจอันเนี้ยไม่ได้เลยต้องมี
เหตุผลไม่ได้ค่ะอันเนี้ย
คุณไม่ไปทำงาน 3 วันเขอาจจะแบบเชิญคุณออก
ไปเลย
ค่ะเพราะว่าไม่มีเหตุผลนะคะแต่เวลาอหแล้ว
อย่างงี้ถ้าเกิดว่าอ่าคิดว่าหลายๆบริษัท
หรือหลายๆออฟฟิศเนาะอ่าไม่ว่าจะทำงาน
เหมือนครูชิครูบีเเนี่ยอื
ถ้าไม่ไปทำงานก็ต้องลาใช่มั้ยคะโอ้โหแต่
มันก็มีลาแบบลาางานหลายๆแบบไงครูชิไม่ใช่
ลามะลิลาไม่ใช่อย่าไม่ไม่ใช่ร้องเพลงนะ
ใช่ใช่อืลาอันแรกค่ะนะคะเราต้องบอกว่าลา
ป่วยอันนี้สำคัญเนาะอืเพเราไม่ได้แข็งแรง
ตลอดเอ 1 ปีไงูชิก็ดูสิเเนี่ยตอนเนี้ยมี
คนไม่สบายมากๆป่วยไปโรงพยาบาลเลยนะอ่า
แล้ววันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสบดี
วันศุกร์เนี่ยเราไปทำงานวันเสาร์วัน
อาทิตย์บางออฟฟิศอาจจะเป็นวันหยุดเออไม่
ต้องไปทำงานแต่พอวันจันทร์เ้านอนอยู่แล้ว
แบบโอ้โหตัวร้อนอ่าอ
พอวัดอุณหภูมิปั้งอ้าไม่ใช่อันนั้นมัน
ปืน 38 องศเซลเซียโอๆๆตัวร้อน่าจะเป็นค
ใช่น่าจะไม่สบายค่ะครูบีต้องไปโรงพยาบาล
น่ะครูบีไปทำงานไม่ได้อันเนี้ยต้องลาอะไร
คะครูชิลาป่วยค่ะอืเรื่องสุขภาพนะอ่าคิด
ว่าใชเราไม่รู้ว่าวันนี้เราจะไม่สบายจะ
ป่วยนะอ่าก็ถ้าไม่สบายแล้วไปโรงพยาบาล
เนี่ยหรือไม่สบายอยู่ที่บ้านอ่าไม่ได้ไป
นอนโรงพยาบาลเราก็ต้องบอกกับที่ทำงานกับ
ออฟฟิศว่าขอลาป่วยใช่มั้ยคะใช่เอ่อตอน
เช้าลุกขึ้นมาปวดหัวไข้ขึ้นขอขอลา 1 วัน
นะคะจะไปโรงพยาบาลหรือไปคลินิกไปไปหาคุณ
หมอนะอันนี้ก็บอกลาได้อันนี้ไม่ต้องลา
ล่วงหน้านะคะอืไม่ต้องลาก่อนเพราะว่าคุณ
ไม่รู้ว่าคุณจะป่วยหรือเปล่าไงไม่ใช่เอ่อ
ดิฉันขอลาพรุ่งนี้ค่ะเพราะคิดคิดว่าพรุ่ง
นี้จะป่วยคิดว่าพรุ่งนี้จะไม่สบายเอ่อบอส
คะดิฉันคิดว่าพรุ่งนี้ดิฉันจะเจ็บคอค่ะ
อ้าอันนี้ไม่ได้ใช่มั้ยคะไม่ได้ค่ะลาป่วย
นี่มันฉุกเฉินไงไม่รู้ว่าเราป่วยไงแล้ว
บางอย่างเนี่ยเวลาที่คุณป่วยอ่ะอืสมมุติ
ว่าคุณเป็นเป็นหวัดอย่างเงี้ยแล้วการที่
คุณป่วยเป็นหวัดคุณควรจะนอนพักให้แข็งแรง
แล้วค่อยกลับมาแต่คุณดันมาทำงานแล้วคุณก็
เอาวัตตมาให้คนอื่นฟรีอีกอันนี้ก็ไม่มี
ใครชอบนะคะ
อ้าเพราะว่าฮัดชิวเนี่ยก็ให้ครูชิฟรีครู
ชิก็เป็นหวัดกับครูบีแต่ตอนนี้มันน่ากว่า
อ่าน่ากลัวกว่านั้นนะูชิโควิดไงคะโอ้โห
เพื่อนๆจะบอกว่าขอร้องอย่ามาค่ะนอนที่
บ้านนอนพักเลยค่ะไม่ต้องเอาไวรัสมาแพร่
ชันค่ะครูบีโทรหาครูชิฮัลโหลครูชิว่ายัง
ไง
บีบีไม่สบายพอดีว่าตรวจ atk ใช่มั้ยเ
เรียก atk ใช่มั้ย
คะใช่ๆๆใช่มอ่ะตรวจแล้วเนี่ยขึ้นสีแดง
เนี่ยขีดสีแดง 2 คิดว่าน่าจะเป็นโควิดออก
ปีไปโรงพยาบาลหาคุณหมอเลยอูยอยากไปทำงาน
มากๆต้องเออไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไม่ต้องค่ะไม่
ต้องมาทำงานนะคะไปพักค่ะไปหาหมอค่ะไป
รักษาให้หายแล้วค่อยมาทำงานไม่ต้องขยันนะ
คะเห็นมเพื่อนๆจะบอกอ้อไม่ต้องมากลัว
ไวรัสนะคะอืไม่ต้องห่วงงานเดี๋ยวพี่ชิทำ
งานให้เองอครูชิสอนให้หน่อยนะคะเออได้ๆ
ได้ค่ะนะอันนี้ครูบีก็ต้องให้ครูชิน่ะบอก
เจ้านายว่าครูบีไม่สบายก็ต้องลาป่วยนะคะ
เออทีนี้การลาเนี่ยก็ขึ้นอยู่กับออฟฟิศ
แต่ละที่นะบางที่อาจจะต้องมีการลาโดย
เขียนเป็นจดหมายคือวันนี้คุณไม่สบายคุณ
โทรศัพท์บอกกับหัวหน้าแล้วเนี่ยคุณอาจจะ
ต้องมีจดหมายเป็นลายลักษณ์อักษรนะว่าคุณ
ลาวันนี้เพราะว่าป่วยไปหาหมอแบบนี้มีค่ะ
ครูบีรู้ว่าจะป่วยก็เลยมี
ใบลาก็คือจะมีแบบฟอร์มของออฟฟิศแต่ละที่
ไม่เหมือนกันก็แล้วแต่นะคะแต่บางที่เนี่ย
อาจจะไม่ต้องถึงขนาดนั้นบางบริษัทบอกว่า
โอ๊ยแค่โทรมาบอกพี่โอเคอืแต่ถ้าคุณลาป่วย
ติดต่อกับกันเนี่ยเกิน 3 วันเนี่ยต้องมี
ใบรับรองแพทย์แล้วนะอืครูมีอ๋อถ้าไม่สบาย
3 วันใช่มั้ยลาป่วยอันนี้คือลาป่วยเนาะ
อ่าลาป่วยก็คือไปโรงพยาบาลเนี่ยใชค่ะอ่า
บางทีเนี่ยเราต้องอ่าให้คุณหมอมีใบใช่
มั้ยคะูชิใช่ค่ะเราเรียกว่าใบรับรองแพทย์
แพทย์ต้องบอกว่าคุณเนี่ยป่วยจริงๆแล้วคุณ
ต้องหยุดอยู่บ้าน 3 วันอืนะคะแต่ถ้าเกิด
เป็นโควิดหมอก็อาจจะต้องเขียนนะว่าต้อง
หยุดเกินกว่า 14 วันอย่างเงี้ยก็ต้องก็
ต้องคุณก็ต้องหยุดนะคะไม่งั้นคุณจะเอา
โควิดไปแพร่เพื่อนนะคะอก็ต้องมีใบรับรอง
จากคุณหมอค่ะครูบดีนะอันนี้ก็คือเป็นใบ
รับรองของคุณหมอแพทย์ก็คือคุณหมอเนาะก็
คือทางโรงพยาบาลเนี่ยอ๋อเข้าใจแล้วตอนที่
ครูบีไม่สบายอ่ะครูชิแล้วก็มาสอนมาสอน
ภาษาไทยไม่ได้เนี่ยอ่าครูบีนอนอยู่โรง
พยาบาลใช่มั้ยตอนนั้นไม่ได้เป็นไวรัส
โควิดอะไรนะคะครูชิค่ะเป็นไข้เลือดออกค่ะ
ยุงกัดอืเออนะไข้เลือดออกก็คุณจะต้องพัก
นะเพราะว่าคุณมาทำงานเนี่ยไม่ได้หรอก
เพราะว่าคุณจะแบบตัวร้อนนะคะแล้วบางทีอาจ
จะมีอาเจียนไงต้องต้องนอนพักค่ะต้องดื่ม
น้ำเยอะๆต้องนอนพักเป็นไข้ไงแล้วตอนนั้น
ครูบีนอนที่โรงพยาบาลเนี่ย 3 วันพอออกจาก
โรง
พยาบาลคุณหมอใช่มั้ยคุณหมอก็ถามนะพยาบาล
ก็ถามนะพอเราจ่ายเงินใช่มั้ยเค้าก็จะถาม
ว่าเอาใบรับรองแพทย์มั้ยคะอ้าอ่าเพราะว่า
บางทีเราต้องเอาหลักฐานของคุณหมอนะไปให้
ที่บริษัทดูไงนี่เห็นมั้ยก็จะเป็นใช่ชื่อ
โรงพยาบาลอ่าแล้วก็เราไม่สบายจริงๆเนาะก็
เอาไปให้บริษัทให้ออฟฟิศที่ทำงานดูนะคะ
ว่าไม่สบายจริงๆใชออือ้าบางบางที่เนี่ย
คุณต้องมีนะต่อให้คุณไม่สบายก็ต้องมีใบ
รับรองแพทย์เพราะว่าถ้าไม่สบายแล้วกินยา
นอนที่บ้านเนี่ยมันก็อาจจะ 1 วัน 2 วันไง
ูชิอแต่ถ้าไปโรงพยาบาลบางครั้งเราต้องนอน
โรงพยาบาล 3 วัน 4 วัน 5 วันอันเนี้ย
ออฟฟิศจะบอกอืมต้องมีใบรับรองแพทย์คือ
หยุดนานไงหยุดหลายวันแบบงานก็จะมีปัญหาไง
ทีนี้มันจะมีผลกระทบกับบริษัทบริษัทก็เลย
ต้องมีใบรับรองไงว่าคุณไม่สบายจริงๆจาก
คุณหมออืแต่ถ้าเกิดบางทีเนี่ยบีอาจจะแบบ
ปวดหัวใช่มยแล้วมาทำงานไม่ไหวเนี่ยแค่นอน
พัก 1 วันก็ก็โอเคแล้วไม่ต้องไปหาคุณหมอ
แบบเนี้ยเอ่อบริษัทก็บอกว่าไม่เป็นไรไม่
ต้องไม่ต้องแบบอะไรอ่ะมีใบรับรองแพทย์ไง
ค่ะคุณอาจจะแบบว่าเป็นหวัดบางคนบอกว่าไม่
กินยาดื่มน้ำเยอะๆแล้วก็นอนเยอะๆก็จะหาย
เองอย่างเงี้ยบางคนก็ไม่ไปหาคุณหมอนะอือ
อืนะอันนี้ก็จะไม่มีใบรับรองแพทย์ใช่มั้ย
คะใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยกฎหมายก็เลยบอก
ว่าถ้าเกิดลาติดกัน 3 วันเนี่ยคุณต้องมี
นะบริษัทบอกคุณต้องมีนะใรับรองแพทย์แต่
ถ้าคุณลา 1 วันลา 2 วันก็โอเคนะฮะอาจจะ
เป็นหวัดแล้วไม่ได้ไปหาหมอไงเค้าก็ยัง
โอเคอยู่อันนี้ก็เป็นลาอันแรกใช่มั้ยคะู
ดีค่ะใช่เราบอกว่าลาป่วยค่ะค่ะอ่ะใช่ที
เนี้ยเราเข้าใจแล้วเนาะว่าลาป่วยเนี่ยก็
จะมีคือ 2 แบบสามารถโทรบอกออฟฟิศแล้ว
ออฟฟิศบอกโอเคอ่าเข้าใจกลับต้องมีใบรับ
รองแพทย์จากโรงพยาบาลอ่าแต่ถ้าเป็นลาอัน
นี้หรอคะ
กูชินี่ค่ะลาอันแรกเลยใช่มั้ยใช่
ลากิอ่าลากิจหมายถึงมีกิจธุระนะคะไม่ใช่
ป่วยคุณแข็งแรงดีแต่บางทีเนี่ยเอ่อญาติๆ
คุณอาจจะเป็นคุณปู่คุณตาคุณยายคุณย่าอื
ตายแล้วคุณต้องไปทำงานศพอืม
เออไปไปเพราะว่าเป็นญาติโดยตรงไงไปร่วม
งานน่ะต้องไปช่วยคุณพ่อคุณแม่ดูแลแขกต้อง
ไปเตรียมของอะไรในพิธีในงานต่างๆอย่าง
เงี้ยคุณไม่สามารถที่จะมาทำงานได้นะแต่
คุณไม่ใช่ไม่สบายนะอันนี้เราเรียกว่าลา
กิจลาไปเพื่อทำธุระอืค่ะเนาะอคืออาจจะมี
คนเสียชีวิตคนตายแล้วก็ไปร่วมงานนะคะอ่า
ก็เป็นลกิหรือถ้าสมมุติครูบีเเนี่ยจะเดิน
ทางไปเที่ยวเกาหลีร่ะค่ะ
โอ้ถ้าเกิดครูบีจะลาไปเอ่อเที่ยวเกาหลี
เนี่ยไม่ต้องอันเนี้ยเราเรียกว่าไม่ใช่
ลิจค่ะเอ้านะคะลากิจไม่ได้หรอก็มีธุระไป
เกาหลีแต่มันไม่ใช่ธุระสำคัญไงลากิจเช่น
เอ่อคุณไปงานศพญาติไปงานบวชญาติหรือไปรับ
มรดกอ่าอ่าคุณพ่อคุณแม่ให้บ้านให้รถในที่
ดินอต้องไปนะอ่ะอ๋อไม่ทำเรื่อง
ครูบีลากิจจะไปเอ่อต่อมแต่งงานไม่ใช่ไปตม
เพราะว่าต้องไปทำพาสปอร์ตต้องไปทำเอกสาร
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเอกสารสำคัญนโอเคทำบัตร
ประชาชนอย่างเงี้ยบัตรประชาชนหมดอายุหรือ
ว่าทำใบขับขี่ครูบีขับรถยนต์แล้วก็เอ่อใบ
ขับขี่เนี่ยจะหมดอายุเดี๋ยวตำรวจจับอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะออันนี้ลกิจได้มั้ย
ได้ค่ะแบบนี้ได้เลยอืมเนาะเพราะว่าบางที
มันมันมีกำหนดเวลาใช่มั้ยอ่าใช่ค่ะอ่า
แล้วบางบริษัทแลก็บางบางที่เนี่ยก็จะมี
บอกไว้เลยค่ะว่าคุณมีสิทธิ์ลิจได้ 1 ปี
เนี่ยไม่เกินกี่วันออกำหนดไว้เลยอ่าใช่
มั้ยอย่างอย่างถ้าเกิดครูชิไปเป็นอะไรอ่ะ
เป็นตำรวจอย่างเงี้ยปีแรกที่ไปเป็นตำรวจ
เนี่ยอาจจะลากกิจได้ไม่เกิน 15  5 วันไง
แต่ถ้าเกิดครูชิเนี่ยเป็นตำรวจนานแล้วครู
ชิอาจจะลากิจได้ปีละไม่เกิน 45 วันอย่า
เงี้ยอืนะไม่ใช่หมายถึงลาครั้งนึง 45 วัน
นะคะอาจจะลา 2 วัน 5 วัน 3 วันแล้วรวมๆ
กันแล้วใน 1 ปีเนี่ยห้ามเกิน 45 วันอื
เนาะอันนี้ก็ต้องดูด้วยใช่มยเวลาชรานะคะ
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าลากิจก็คือมีธุระต้องไป
ทำนะเป็นเรื่องที่จำเป็นจริงๆนะคะใช่ค่ะ
แต่ถ้าที่ครูบีบอกว่าครูบีเเนี่ยอยากจะไป
เที่ยวเกาหลีอ่ะอืแล้วครูบีอยากจะลาอัน
นี้เราเรียกว่าลาพัก
ร้อนลาพักร้อนทำไมคะอากาศร้อนเหรอคะไม่
ว่าไม่ว่าจะร้อนจะหนาวจะฝนตกก็ลาพักร้อน
ค่ะก็คือง่ายๆลาไปพักผ่อน
อืมโออันนี้ก็ก็ต้องก็ก็ต้องขึ้นอยู่กับ
แต่ละบริษัทแต่ละออฟฟิศว่าคุณสามารถลาพัก
ร้อนได้กี่วันอย่างงี้หรอคะหรือตามกฎหมาย
เลยูชิคือในบริษัทเขาจะมีกำหนดค่ะบาง
บริษัทบอกว่าคุณทำงานเนี่ย
เอ่อเพิ่งมาทำงานปีแรกเนี่ยก็ได้ลาพัก
ร้อน 10 วันไงอือย่างเงี้ยคุณจะลาในช่วง
ไหนก็ได้นะคะใน 1 ปีนะคะแต่ถ้าเกปได้ 10
วันใช่นะคะหรือบางคนบอกว่าคุณทำงานไปจน
แบบว่าเอ่อ 10 ปีแล้วอย่างเงี้ยคุณอาจจะ
มีสิทธิ์พักร้อนที่มากขึ้นอือ่าอาจจะลา
ได้แบบ 30 วัน
อ่าอันนี้ก็เป็นก็ขึ้นอยู่กับบริษัทใช่อื
ก็เหมือนนักเรียนชาวต่างชาติเนาะครูบีก็
คิดว่าน่าจะลาพักร้อนมาเที่ยวประเทศไทยนะ
คะ 3
เดือนดีมากเลยอ่ะูชิแแต่อันนี้นะครูบีลา
กิจกับลาลาพักร้อนเนี่ยคุณต้องลาล่วงหน้า
ค่ะโดยเฉพาะลาพักร้อนคุณต้องลายาวใช่มั้ย
ไปเที่ยวเกาหลีเนี่ยครูบีคงไม่ไปเที่ยว
เกาหลี 1 วันอาจจะไปไปไปเที่ยว 1 สัปดาห์
อย่างเงี้ยอไม่เอาเอา 10 วันเออถ้า 10
วันอย่างเงี้ยครูบีก็ต้องเขียนใบลาล่วง
หน้าแล้วครูบีก็ต้องเคลียร์งานให้ได้มาก
ที่สุดน่ะเพื่อให้มีผลกระทบกับบริษัทน้อย
ที่สุดอ๋อแปลว่าครูบีเเนี่ยจะลกิจใช่มั้ย
อ่าอ่านี่เลยครูบีก็ต้องอ่าลากกิจแล้วก็
เขียนอ่าวันที่ต้องเขียนใช่อันนี้ต้อง
เขียนอะไรเนี่ยอันนี้อันลากิจกับลาลาพร
พักร้อนเนี่ยครูบีต้องเขียนลาล่วงหน้าอ่า
ถ้าลากิจครูบีเเนี่ยจะไปทำบัตรประชาชนอ่า
ครูบีเขียนวันวันที่นะอ่าลาล่วงหน้าอ่า
วันเนี้ยวันพฤหัสบใช่มั้ยแต่ครูบีจะลา
พรุ่งนี้ค่ะครูชิอโอเคพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 15
อ่าคือถ้าถ้าเอ่อบริษัทไม่ได้กำหนดไว้คุณ
คุณจะลาพรุ่งนี้แล้วไม่มีปัญหาก็ได้แต่
มากๆแล้วเขให้ยื่นใบลาล่วงหน้าก่อน 3 วัน
ที่คุณจะไปอ่างั้นก็เป็นวันที่เท่าไหร่จะ
ไปพรุ่งนี้ก็ต้องลาตั้งแต่วันอังคารแล้ว
ค่ะ
โองั้นวันอังคารอังคารพุธพฤหัสบดีวัน
ศุกร์ไปอ่าวันอังคารนะวัน
ที่ 10  2  12 ใช่อ่าใช่มั้ยแล้วก็เขียน
วันที่แล้วก็เดือนเนาะอันนี้ก็เดือนเดือน
ที่ 12 นะแล้วก็ก็ปีแล้วก็ไปไหน
เออจะไปทำบัตรประชาชนอ่านะแล้วก็เขียน
ชื่อตัวเองเนาะอ๋ออันนี้คือเราต้องเขียน
แล้วก็เอาไปให้ออฟฟิศเนี่ยล่วงหน้าก่อน 3
วันเหรอคะูชิใช่ค่ะเพื่อให้ให้เขารับรู้
ว่าวันเนี้ยคุณมีธุระจะไปที่อื่นเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้ามีงานของคุณเนี่ยเขาจะได้
มอบให้กับคนอื่นได้นะคะแล้วคนอื่นก็จะรู้
ว่าวันเนี้ยครูบีลานะเดี๋ยวพรุ่งเนี้ครู
บีลาเพราะฉะนั้นงานของครูบีเเนี่ยอาจจะ
ต้องแบบให้คนอื่นทำให้ไงให้ครูชิทำค่ะได้
นะอ๋อมันมันเหมือนเป็นลากิจกับเ่อลาพัก
ร้อนเนี่ยต้องรู้ก่อนนะแล้วก็ต้องลาล่วง
หน้าอ่าเขียนตั้งแต่วันที่ 12 ใช่มั้ยอ่า
แล้วพรุ่งนี้ครูบีไม่อยู่อ่าครูบีก็ไปไป
เ่อทำใบขับขี่ได้นะเพื่อนๆก็จะรู้ใช่มย
ว่าต้องทำงานแทนครูบีครูชิต้องสอนแทนครู
บีอย่างเงี้ยอือันนี้คือลลาพักร้อนใช่ลา
พักร้อนก็เหมือนกันต้องเขียนล่วงหน้า
อย่างน้อย 3 วันใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าบางบริษัท
บอกว่าคุณต้องเขียนให้กับหัวหน้าหัวหน้า
ต้องเสนออนุมัติอะไรแบบเนี้ยถึงจะได้ผ่าน
ว่าคุณได้ได้ลาไปเกาหลีจริง
ๆอ๋อต้องมีคนเซ็นด้วยออใช่นะนะคะอ่ะคือ
รับรู้เพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยลาพักร้อนเ่ะมัน
อาจจะไปตรงกันไงอย่างเช่นช่วงสงกรานต์น่ะ
อืในประเทศไทยเ่ะจะมีวันหยุด 3 วันบางคน
อาจจะลาพักร้อนต่อเนื่องไงเพื่อจะได้อยู่
กับครอบครัวนานๆน่ะและถ้าเกิดคนคิดอย่าง
นี้เหมือนๆกัน 10 คนบริษัทก็ไม่ต้องทำงาน
ใช่คะอ๋อไม่มีคนทำงานเพราะว่าลาพักร้อน
หลายลงกันหมดใช่เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบริษัท
อาจจะมีกำหนดไว้นะคุณลาล่วงหน้าแล้วเนี่ย
แต่คุณจองตรงนี้ไว้เนี่ยวันเนี้ยช่วงวัน
เนี้ยหมดสิทธิ์คนที่จะมาลาหลังจากนี้ไม่
ได้ะแล้วเพราะว่าลาลากัน 7 คนแล้วไม่ไหว
ละถ้าเกิดลาอีกคนนึงเนี่ยงานมีปัญหาแน่ๆ
อือันนี้ก็เป็นลาพักร้อนนะคะก็ต้องล่วง
หน้านะแล้วก็ส่วนมากคนก็จะไปเที่ยวไปพัก
ผ่อนก็อย่างน้อยก็ 6 วันนะเออไปเชียงใหม่
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะคุณไปภูเก็ตก็คงไม่ลา 3 วัน
นะคะลาพักร้อนนะอ่ะก็มีอีกลาอีกอันนึงค่ะ
ูชิสงสัยค่ะค่ะอ่าเพราะว่าครูบีไม่เคยลา
เลยค่ะอ้าวเหรอเพราะว่าลากิจลาป่วยลาพัก
ร้อนเนี่ยครูบีเคยมาหมดแล้วแต่ลาอันนี้
ครูบีไม่เคยลาเหรอคะไม่เคยค่ะเพราะว่าครู
บีไม่เคยท้อง
อ๋อครูชิคิดว่าลาบวชไม่เคยบวชเป็นพระอ๋อ
ลาโคตไม่เคยท้องก็เลยไม่ต้อง
ลาค่ะท้องแล้วก็ไปคลอดลูกที่โรงพยาบาล
เนี่ย
คะอันเนี้ยลาคลอดได้นะคะอคุณก็มีสิทธิ์ลา
คลอดได้ไม่เกิน 90 วันอืมได้ 90 วันเลย
ค่ะคุณบีเออเนาะเพราะว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยเวลา
แต่งงานมีสามีใช่มั้ยแล้วก็ท้องอ่าพอเรา
ท้องเนี่ยก็ต้องท้องคือช่วงเวลาที่ท้องก็
ต้องมาทำงานใช่
มยช่วงเวลาท้องยังทำงานได้อยู่
ค่ะพอจะคลอดโอ้ปวดท้องโอ้โหเจ็บท้องเหรอ
เจ็บท้องคลอดเนี่ยนะใช่ค่ะอันเนี้ยจะคลอด
ลูกแล้วเนี่ยต้องลางานอันนี้ลาได้นานที่
สุดเลยเนาะใช่ค่ะทีเนี้ยผู้หญิงมีสิทธิ์
ลาเพื่อที่จะไปคลอดลูกเนี่ยบางบบริษัทก็
เลยชอบผู้หญิงที่ไม่แต่งงานมากจะได้ไม่มี
การลาคลอดนะคอเนาะหรือบางทีก็ชอบเอ่อรับ
พนักงานที่เป็นผู้ชายเพราะผู้ชายไม่ท้อง
อืนะอันนี้เพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่าในออฟฟิศใน
บริษัทใช่มั้ยมีผู้หญิงท้อง 5 คนเโอ้ก็จะ
มีคนลาคลอดบ่อยๆใช่มั้ย
อ่าบริษัก็จะ 1 ใครูชิลาคลอดอ่าพอทำงานทำ
งานไปอ้าคนนี้ครูบีลาคลอดครูปุ๊กลาคลอด
ใช่มั้แต่ไม่ได้คลอดพร้อมกันนะแต่หมายถึง
พนักงานที่ทำงานมันก็จะมีคนลาบ่อยๆบ่อยๆ
อ่าก็จะไม่มีคนทำงานใช่มั้ยคะอืแต่ก็มีคน
ที่สามารถลาได้นานกว่า 90 วันนะครูิมีลา
อะไรอ่ะมีก็ลาบวชไงเอ้า
ลาบวชไปบวชเป็นพระนี่เหรอคะใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าลาบวชเนี่ยก็เรารู้อยู่ว่าเวลาเข้า
พรรษาใช่มั้ยเวลาจะมีช่วงเข้าพรรษาเนี่ย
อย่างน้อยคุณต้องบวชเป็นพระเนี่ย 3 เดือน
อแล้วคุณต้องเตรียมตัวก่อนบวชอีกอ่ะคุณ
ต้องเตรียมตัวล่วงหน้าใช่มั้ยต้องไปนอน
วัดใส่ชุดสีขาวต้องไป
เอ่อเรียนอะไรนะพภาภาษาบาลีสันสกฤตเนี่ย
อืวิธีการสวดมนต์เพื่อที่จะขออนุญาตบวช
เนี่ยก็ต้องไปเรียนก่อนค่ะเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยเอ่อลาบวชก็สามารถลาได้นานนะถ้าเป็น
ข้าราชการแต่บริษัทมากๆเนี่ยจะไม่ค่อยให้
คนลาบวชนานแบบ 3 เดือนไปเลยนะอืก็เราก็
เลยจะมีการแบบบวชตามประเพณีคนไทยใช่มั้ย
จริงๆต้องบวชแบบอยู่วัด 3 เดือนเนี่ยบาง
คนบอกลาบวช 15 วันเนี่ยเอาเอาแค่แบบครึ่ง
เดือนพออืนะไม่ไม่ไม่ต้องแบบไม่ต้องถึง
เดือนใช่มั้ยคะใช่เพราะว่าถ้าเป็นถ้าเป็น
ข้าราชการนะลาบวชของคนไทยใช่มั้ยหรือลาไป
พิธีอะไรพิธีฮัจญ์ของคนอิสลามอ่ะเขา
สามารถขออนุญาตลาได้ 120 วันเลยนะ
อืมใช่ 120 วันใช่
อู้นานนะชิเพราะว่ามันมันคือเค้าต้องต้อง
ก็อย่างที่บอกต้องบวชบวช 3 เดือนน่ะนะคะ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบางบริษัทถึงบอกไงว่าก็
เลยต้องมีข้อกำหนดค่ะนะว่าคุณสามารถลาบวช
ได้แต่ไม่ต้องอยู่ถึงครบ 3 เดือน 1 พรรษา
คือ 3 เดือนใช่มั้ยอืก็ลาแค่ 15 วันก็
บ๊ายบายจากพระยังไม่รู้ว่าสวดนะโมตัสสะอื
เก่งหรือยังนะก็ต้องไอ้นี่แล้วอันนี้บวช
ตามประเพณีคนไทยไงอ๋อก็คือว่าเวลาบวชเป็น
พระเนี่ยก็ต้องมีการเตรียมตัวใช่มั้ยใน
เรื่องของใช่อ่านหนังสืออ่านบาลีสันสกฤต
อ่าแล้วก็ต้องมีเวลาที่จะเตรียมงานบวช
เนาะเ่อซึ่งเอ่อคนไทยเนี่ยก็ถือว่าเวลา
บวชเนี่ยก็จะโอ้โหต้องใส่ชุดสีขาวต้องโกน
ผมใช่มั้ยผู้ชายไทยนะคะอืก็จะประมาณนี้
เลยเนาะูชิอันนี้เราบอกว่าใชผู้ชายนะผู้
หญิงก็ไม่น่าจะมีนะลาบวชอืไม่มีค่ะนะ
เพราะผู้หญิงไม่มีแบบบวชเป็นพระนะในใน
ศาสนาพุทธอันนี้ก็ต้องเตรียมตัวแล้วนะอ่า
ที่ต้องโกนผมนะคะแล้วก็ต้องเข้าพิธีที่
นี่เนาะอ่าก็เปลี่ยนชุดสีเหลืองนะเป็นพระ
นะคะอย่างเ้าพรรษาต้องเป็นพระเนี่ยตั้ง
แต่เดือนเดือนที่ 7 อย่างเงี้ยบางทีอ่ะ
เดือนที่ 5 เดือนที่ 6 คนเริ่มบวชกันแล้ว
ไงค่ะเริ่มมีงานบวชแล้วก็อยู่วัดยาว 3
เดือน 4 เดือนนะคะอืแต่พอถึงเวลาทำงานคุณ
ลานานๆแบบนั้นน่ะอาจจะมีผลกับการทำงานก็
เลยไม่นิยมไงบางบริษัทก็เลยจะมีข้อตกลง
ว่าคุณอาจจะลาบวชได้บริษัทให้มีสิทธิ์ลา
บวชได้คุณจะลาบวช 3 เดือนก็ได้แต่บริษัท
จะจ่ายเงินเดือนให้คุณเนี่ยแค่ 1 เดือน 2
เดือนเดือนที่ 3 ไม่ให้แล้วนะอ่าอืมอัน
นี้ก็ต้องตกลงกับบริษัทใช่มั้ยคะใช่อ่ะก็
เป็นเรื่องปกติเนาะบางทีเนี่ยถ้าลาบวช
เห็นมั้ยคะบางทีเนี่ยเขาก็จะบวชกันหลายๆ
คนอย่างงี้เลยนะูชิโอ้ใช่ค่ะอ่าก็อยู่ที่
วดเป็นหมู่คณะใช่แล้วแต่ว่าคุณบวชได้กี่
วันนะแต่บริษัทก็ไม่อยากให้คุณหยุดนาน
อยู่แล้วนะคะอือหืออ่าอันนี้ก็ลาบวชเนาะ
ส่วนมากก็เป็นผู้ชายนะเพราะผู้หญิงก็ไม่
มีอ่าการลางานไม่มีไปลาบวชใช่ผู้หญิงอยาก
เป็นพระยังมีลาอีกนะคะครูบีลาไปเป็นทหาร
ค่ะเพราะว่ากฎหมายไทยอ่ะผู้ชายอายุ 20
ยังต้องเป็นทหารอยู่ไงอืมโอเนาะลาไปเป็น
ทหารนี่มันจะลาได้กี่วันกี่เดือนกี่ปีหรอ
คะูชิเค้าบอกว่าถ้าเกิดลาเพื่อไปเป็นทหาร
เนี่ยจริงๆก็ต้องไปเป็นทหาร 2 ปีถูกมั้ย
ค่ะแต่จะได้เงินเดือนเนี่ยอาจจะแค่ 2
เดือนไงอืหลังจากนั้นเนี่ยคุณลาได้ค่ะแต่
คุณจะไม่ได้เงินเดือน
อือันนี้บริษัทไม่ให้เพราะว่าไม่ได้งาน
จากคุณไงอือืนะคะนะก็อ่าเป็นทหาร 2 ปีนะ
ก็ลางานกับบริษัทได้เพื่อที่จะไปเป็นทหาร
อืหรือถ้าเกิดคุณอะไรนะเอ่อสมัครเป็นทหาร
ใช่มั้ยไม่ไปจับใบสีดำใบสีแดงเนี่ยคุณก็
เป็นทหารแค่ 6 เดือนเป็น 1 ปีแล้วก็เอ่อ
ทำงานอก 6 เดือนก็อันนี้ก็ลาปีนึงใช่่
มั้ยแต่ได้เงินเดือนแค่ 2 เดือนเนะที่
เหลือก็ไม่ได้เงินเดือนนะอ๋อบริสัตว์ก็
ไม่จ่ายอ่าใช่ครูบีก็คิดว่าผู้ชายหลายๆคน
เนาะก็ไปเป็นทหารก็คือเหมือนบางทีก็หยุด
งานไปเลยเพราะว่าบริษัทก็ไม่จ่ายเงิน
เดือนให้อยู่แล้วใช่อืมนะคะลาสุดท้ายค่ะ
ค่ะออยังมีลาอีกเหรอคะูชิมีค่ะลาอะไรค่ะ
ลาออกค่ะอย่างงี้ต้องลา
ออก
บ๊าย
บายไม่อยากทำงานแล้วเอ๊ะหรือว่าเจ้านาย
บอกออก
ไปลาบ่อยมากไม่สบายบ่อยไออกถ้าเจ้านายไล่
ออกหรือว่าเชิญครับออกไปเนี่ยเจ้านายจะ
ต้องจ่ายเงินให้ใช่มั้ย 3 เดือนล่วงหน้า
ค้าตกใจอีก 1 เดือนโอได้ 4 เดือนแต่ถ้า
เราเขียนจดหมายบ๊ายบายบริษัทลาออกเองไม่
ได้อะไรเลยนะ
อืเห็นมอันนี้ก็ลาออกก็คือเราอาจจะเบื่อ
ไม่อยากทำงานที่นี่แล้วอ่ะไปหางานใหม่อื
ไปหาออฟฟิศใหม่อย่างเงี้ยค่ะอันนี้ก็คือ
เขียนใบลาออกไปเลยอือือหือนะอ่ะหมดหรือ
ยังคะยังมีอีกมั้ยคะหมดแล้วค่ะยังมีลา
อะไรอีกลาออกกันตอนนี้เราต้องลาแล้วค่ะลา
ทุกๆคนไปก่อนนะแล้วมาเจอกันใหม่ยังไม่ออก
ค่ะครูชิเรายังทำงานอยู่เราลาแล้วเพราะ
ว่ามันหมดเวลาออก็ต้องสวัสดีนักเรียนทุก
คนแล้วก็ขอบคุณครูบีนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะทุกคน